welcome to this video DD mr. GD and he's
going for the Kings gambit now this guy
has an agenda he wants to win what's
this Queenie 7 or just back i don't know
i don't remember that to be honest this
is slide I haven't looked at it for I
mean ages ago I mean this is all very
tough to believe and now you go back
with your night yeah that is really the
way this is played you cannot sacrifice
a PCM ok so Bishop age six or what to
keep this I guess
what the wacky opening up Queen f6
what are you doing now king kings before
the king c-4 would have been cute um
okay but he's got 95 now in the mix of3
that's 95 hmm okay so maybe this movie
md5 95 at night b5 I can castle long if
everything else fails and threatening f3
anyway wow really I can give this check
here baby jack now maybe you can go to
see 3 we have 97 as well I mean yeah
here there's be 5 or is there is there
made somewhere it looks close to that
okay let's let's give the dead gets a
second at least now we cannot take a
queen takes d5 I wow hey this I really
have some doubts about where is where is
the checkmate where is the maid okay
come on this this must be this must be
right yeah and now let's let's have a
look there for the maid check here be
four and a five threatening a takes
before check media there's no defense
check
v 4 a 5 threatening hxb form mate and
that's it yep he's got no check he
cannot attack the room there's ice
that's the Kings gambit for you yeah
well no this is really a king this
Knight c3 is one of those super wacky
lines where white is even allowing this
this kind of business I don't know what
is wrong and what is right here there
are I think a number of good lines there
is this outline d5 this d6 I mean I was
just thinking that well you have got a
king only two around here I think
actually black is winning already I mean
he has to retreat this night now this is
never ever good I mean I'm a porn up I
have an attack I mean that's not that's
not really working ok Jack Jack Jack
that's the quickest mate wow that was
fun they should do that more often right
to make for good entertainment ok thanks
for watching